and when thou would solace gather
when our child's first accents flow
wilt thou teach her to say father
though his care she must forgo
those are the words of a poet named lord
byron
written about his daughter ada as he was
separating from her mother
just weeks after ada was born
ada would marry and go on to become ada
king
countess of lovelace or known as
ada lovelace and she's often referred to
as the first ever computer programmer
that is all i had heard about her
until recently when i wondered what does
that really mean
and is it even true well the best way to
find out is to read the document that
she's famous for
it's the only paper that she published
and it's called
sketch of the analytical engine it is
this document that will allow us to
understand ada's role in the history of
computing
so in this video i would like to go
through it with you
it describes the analytical engine
invented by charles babbage
which was a monstrously ambitious
steam-powered computer
that will cover the mechanical aspects
of the engine
just enough to be able to understand
some of the programs that ada wrote for
it
gossip about her private affairs
gambling
and interesting philosophies although
fascinating
will have to be left for another video a
sketch of the analytical engine
was published in 1843 and the first part
of it was a paper published by an
italian mathematician
who would actually go on to become the
prime minister of italy
luigi menebrea ada translated his work
into english
and then added her own notes to it and
these notes were twice as long as the
original paper
at the time ada had already been
acquainted with charles babbage for a
number of years
and had been working alongside him to
understand
the engine it was in these notes that
she
included an algorithm that could use the
engine
to compute bernoulli numbers and it is
this which is called the
first computer program she also notes
that
the engine could be used to do things
other than arithmetic
and computations she has this idea that
quantities other than numbers could be
represented in the engine
and could therefore go on to be used for
things like
composing music this insight and vision
a hundred years before alan turing would
come along with his
own ideas of the modern computer are
really quite remarkable
and is something that she definitely
deserves to be credited for
as well so let's start at the beginning
it was
charles babbage who was the mastermind
behind this
first computer and he was frustrated by
mistakes that crept into
logarithm tables used back then for
calculations
he wanted to execute by means of
machinery
the mechanical branch of scientific
labors
reserving for pure intellect that which
depends on reasoning
so really he wants to free up the
scientist's mind
charles babbage first came up with the
difference engine
and in this example here we have the
series of whole
square numbers 1 4 9 16
25 and so on if we find the difference
between each of these numbers
we'll get a new series 3 5 7
9 11 and the difference between each of
these numbers
is always equal to 2. it is shown in
this table here
and from this if we were given just the
numbers
2 5 and 9 we would be able to
reconstruct this entire series of square
numbers
just through a series of additions for
the machine
we would have three dials a b and c
and also two hammers so if we start by
placing needle c
on two needle b on five and needle a on
nine then the hammer on c will strike
twice
adding two onto needle b so b will now
read
7 it will then strike its hammer 7 times
adding 7 onto 9 and giving us the result
16. if we recommence these operations
beginning with the needle c which is
always to be left
on two we will successively reproduce
the series of whole
square numbers by means of a very simple
mechanism
babbage himself ran out of money to ever
finish building the difference
engine although he did have a small
model of it
since then some clever people have
finished it for him
and made a complete version babbage kind
of got distracted
by his idea for a second type of engine
one that could do a lot more
and was much more ambitious this was the
analytical engine
the analytical engine can perform
addition subtraction multiplication and
division
and is therefore capable of performing
every species of numerical calculation
for the analytical engine we have a
series of vertical columns
consisting of a number of circular disks
the first disk represents units the
second
tens the third hundreds and so on
babbage's notes showed as many as 40
disks
so you could have quite some precision
they haven't had the idea of using
binary numbers so everything is in
decimal
we denote these columns with v for
variable and for example if we wanted to
add the numbers on v1
and v4 together we would then place the
result
on a third column we could call that v7
the act of adding the numbers together
will occur
at a place on the engine called the mill
the mill is the portion of the machine
which works
and the columns of variables constitute
that where the results are represented
and arranged
so in modern computing notation the mill
may be called the cpu and the columns of
variables
this big extension out the back of the
machine
would be called the store or the memory
you may wonder how the machine knows
which operations to perform
and which variables to include and the
solution has been taken from
jacquard's apparatus what they're
talking about here
is using punch cards that were first
used in jacquard's loom
something that was used to make
intricate patterns in lace and other
materials by using a series of cards
as the instructions there are two main
types of cards that will allow us
to program the engine the first are the
operation
cards and these are telling the machine
if you want to perform
addition subtraction multiplication or
division
and the second type of card is the card
of the variables
which indicate to the machine the
columns on which the results are to be
represented
there's then a fairly brief example and
you may even want to call this the first
computer program
since it's the first example in the
notes but it's much more simple
than the bernoulli program which will
appear later
in this we have two simultaneous
equations
and say that we want to solve for x well
we can rearrange these equations
into this fraction here then we assign
our eight variables to eight different
columns n and n dash have been
represented twice
probably because they will need to be
used twice in
separate parts of the calculation this
table then gives an idea of the cards
that would be needed to execute this
here we have the number of the operation
so
first step second step third step and so
on then in the next column here
these are our set of operation cards
they're just saying that we're either
performing a multiplication
a subtraction or a division and these
are the cards of the variables
telling the machine which variables are
involved
in each of these operations so we have
here
v2 times v4 and that result is going to
be put on the column
v8 this box here just shows what we're
doing
that was the step of multiplying d by n
dash
following all these steps and the last
one will end up giving you
the result for x since the cards just
tell the machine
what columns and what operations to do
we still need to
enter the initial numerical data
ourselves
so there's still a little bit of room
for a human error in here
what's interesting is that the method of
running the engine
is actually turing complete which wasn't
a phrase that existed at the time
but essentially means it would be able
to perform
any computation although in this case it
is limited by
being steam powered we are now on to the
first of ada's notes
this one is note a it is quite
philosophical and poetic she says in it
that the machine might act upon other
things besides number
supposing for instance that the
fundamental relations of
pitched sounds in the science of harmony
and musical composition were susceptible
of such expression and adaptations
the engine might compose elaborate and
scientific pieces of music
of any degree of complexity or extent
she says that whether the inventor of
this engine
had any such views in his mind while
working out the invention
or whether he may subsequently ever have
regarded it under this phase
we do not know but it is one that
forcibly occurred to ourselves
on becoming acquainted with the means
through which analytical combinations
are actually attained by the mechanism
she's saying that there are some things
that are very clear to her
but she's not sure if charles babbage
even shares the same views
she even speaks of the intrinsic beauty
of the
mathematics behind this she says that
this science constitutes the language
through which
alone we can adequately express the
great facts of the natural world
those who thus think on mathematical
truth
as the instrument through which the weak
mind of a man
can most effectually read his creator's
works
will regard with special interest all
that can tend to facilitate the
translation of its principles
into explicit practical forms i love
this sentence here where she says that
the analytical engine
weaves algebraic patterns just as the
jacquard loom
weaves flowers and leaves she's seeing
how they can take the beautiful patterns
from
lace and material and translate that
into the beauty of mathematics
the other big idea that she deserves to
be remembered for
is recognizing that the analytical
engine
is unlike anything before it she says
here that
the engine does not occupy common ground
with mere calculating machines
and she spends a lot of the notes
pointing out the differences between the
difference engine
and this much more powerful analytical
engine
doing so was important in its own right
but it was also
slightly political in a way because
charles babbage was trying really hard
to get enough funding for
to build his analytical engine and with
his track record of running
out of money to build the difference
engine he was really struggling to
convince people of its value and of its
difference
ada then says something which still
rings true today
in the pursuit of trying to convince
people that
doing research or building machines or
projects
that might not have as much immediate
value
can still bring a lot of value down the
line that we are not even aware of
she says those who incline to very
strictly utilitarian views
may perhaps feel that the peculiar
powers of the analytical
engine bear upon questions of abstract
and speculative science
rather than upon those involving
everyday and
ordinary human interests these persons
being likely to possess
but little sympathy or possibly
acquaintance
with any branches of science which they
do not find to be
useful according to their definition of
that word
may conceive that the undertaking of
that engine
now that the other one is already in
progress
would be a barren and unproductive
laying out of yet
more money and labor however she
continues that while
some of the results of the analytical
engine
may be known now others which it may not
yet be possible to foresee
but which would be brought forth by the
daily increasing requirements of science
and with practical acquaintance with the
powers of the engine
were it in actual existence she sounds
like anyone today trying to justify
some of these more abstract or blue sky
research ideas and mathematics or
even things like investing in space
technology and exploration
unfortunately due to the lack of funds
and lack of mechanical and technical
abilities back then
they weren't able to actually build the
analytical engine
and i wonder what kind of insights and
developments
might have happened if they actually had
one of these in existence
it would be quite a long time before we
would converge back
on these ideas let's move on to ada's
last note
the famous note g it starts off with a
comment that is surprisingly relevant
here
she says that in considering any new
subject
there is frequently a tendency first to
overrate what we find to be already
interesting or remarkable
and secondly by a sort of natural
reaction
to undervalue the true state of the case
when we do discover that our notions
have surpassed those that were really
tenable
she may be talking about the engine and
not wanting to overstate its abilities
but the sentiment also is true for
her role in the history of computing
with the claims that she is the first
ever computer programmer perhaps she has
been sometimes
overrated but then when people look
more into the case and start to say well
you know
charles babbage has written programs of
his own and some of his notes
there is a risk to undervalue the true
work that ada has done
and we shouldn't do that because through
these notes i
hope that it comes across that she
speaks with intelligence
with a lot of knowledge of the
analytical engine
and of its potential in a way that
nobody
else at the time did and she definitely
deserves to be valued
and now finally we get to the really
juicy stuff
which is this computer program to
compute
the numbers of bernoulli the bernoulli
numbers
are involved with trying to calculate
the sum
of positive integers to any given power
throughout history a lot of people tried
to do this and it was really difficult
jacob bernoulli came up with a way to do
this which
wasn't quite easy but at least was
easier than any other method
he found that the sum of the first
positive n
integers to any given power followed a
pattern
and the coefficients of each term in
this pattern
could be broken down into two factors
one set of these factors
the a's could be obtained from pascal's
triangle
and the other set the b's were called
the bernoulli numbers
and they themselves followed a pattern
and could be worked out
using what's in the box up here ada
herself
acknowledges in the notes that this is a
rather complicated example to be given
and not that easy to follow the
mathematical derivation
but she gives it as a way to illustrate
the very powerful abilities of the
engine
her program computes these bernoulli
numbers
and it does so in terms of all the
preceding ones
she says that she appends to this note a
diagram
and table containing the details of the
computation for b7
given b1 b3 and b5
and this is that program it's computing
b to the 2n minus 1 in the case
of n being equal to 4. we have
the number of operation that we're up to
and we have the operation cards in here
multiply subtract add and divide
we then have the variable cards telling
us which variables are involved in the
operation
and where their result will go we also
have this
indication of change in the value on any
variable
to keep track of variable columns that
are changing we have our statement of
results to see
what step in the computation we are up
to
and then we have written here what our
variables
actually are in our case there will be
six
inputs into the program we will need to
put in
one 2 our n
which is 4 and b1
b3 and b5 that's what we need to get to
b7
although we are actually working out
these values
as we go if we have stopped earlier in
the process
before we got to b7 in this very first
step where we multiply
v2 by v3 we multiply
2 by n and we put the result
two n onto these three columns here
because we're going to want to use those
later we return the two
and the n back to where they came from
because we're also going to want to use
those again
in the case where we don't use the value
again we replace it with
a zero so we proceed through some of the
steps of the algebra here
and the last line in this first section
here
is doing n minus one equal to three
we're taking our column where n is
stored so it was initially four
and we're subtracting one from it to be
left with a new
n which is equal to three because n
is now equal to 3 we're going to
continue on the process
and then in the next step we'll decrease
into 2
and so on the section of lines down here
13 to 23 are very interesting because
every time n increases we just need to
do
an additional repetition of these
operations 13 to 23.
because of that when n is bigger than 2
25 operation cards are used but
no more are needed regardless of how
great
n may be we will however have to add
more variable cards every time
n goes up and ada refers to this as
being a
cycle of operations and since these
operations use the same pairs of columns
they are actually a cycle of variable
cards
so this computer kind of has loops
it might not be a for loop or a while
loop but it is
a loop of cards that can be fed back
into the machine
to continue computing the same cycle of
operations
over and over again and down here she
shows what that looks like
she says that applying the notation for
cycles
we may express the operations for
computing the numbers of the newly in
the following manner
for b1 b3 b5 and b7
we all have the same initial set of
seven
operations we finish with the same pair
of operations at the end
in the middle we might have this set of
operations from 8 to 12
and then a cycle of operations repeating
those from
line 13 to 23 with a general formula
down here
to compute any bernoulli number and what
you're looking at here
is the seed of computer programming that
would go on to be
so prevalent and so important to run our
modern world
ada died nine years after the paper was
published
but nobody involved in the project lived
long enough to see the dream be realized
in fact we still haven't built a version
of the analytical engine
although i think it is still a dream of
many people
ada was motivated and highly intelligent
and she was definitely the first person
to
clearly communicate the ideas of
a substantial computer program charles
babbage
had of course written smaller programs
in his own notes
since he is the person who came up with
how the engine would work
and he did help ada with a lot of the
mathematics but it was her who wrote it
down
and wrote it down in a way that made it
clear what this
engine was capable of and maybe it was
her
who saw more than babbage did what
really the potential was
that they were dealing with it was very
rare in these times for a woman to
even have a mathematical education but
ada did
and the reason that she did was because
ada's mother
tried very hard to steer ada away
from becoming like her poet father lord
byron
she didn't want ada to study poetry or
literature or things like that
instead she steered her into studying
mathematics and science
hoping that that wouldn't result in her
sharing the same
madness that ada's mother saw in ada's
father
however it wasn't so easy to completely
remove poetic tendencies from
ada because she saw her approach
kind of as a poetic science perhaps it
was
those poetic tendencies that allowed her
to see the far-reaching potentials of
this technology
and to see beyond its pure mathematical
abilities
in the end ada chose to be buried
alongside her father
and although their accomplishments were
very different
i guess there was a thread that tied
them together
[Music]
thanks as always to my patreon
supporters for making these videos
possible
and a reminder that i've started a
podcast over on my patreon
called natural wonders and there are
five episodes up
already a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day
punk rock thanks for watching and i hope
to see you next time